Laverne Cox is applauding the Supreme
Court's decision that gay and
transgender workers are now protected by
law while promoting her new Netflix
documentary disclosure the actress and
activist says the new ruling is a
landmark victory an incredible victory a
landmark victory it for me
reaffirms that average everyday people
can make a change
Amy Stevens she wrote a letter to her
employer saying you know I've struggled
with this for very very long time but I
got transgender and I have to live my
truth and I'll be returning to work as
myself and she was fired she was fired
she did not live to see this decision
done
Zarda did not live to see this decision
he passed away in 2014 but it is a
victory for the everyday American I
think the new ruling makes it illegal
for an employer to fire someone
due to their gender identity or sexual
orientation and the verge says it is a
shock that a court judge appointed by
President Trump wrote the majority
opinion I think it's shocking because we
have a conservative majority on the
Supreme Court and me'll Gorsuch wrote
the majority opinion obviously a trompe
appointee it's that's the shocking part
the fact that it should not be legal to
fire someone from their job in the
United States of America for being who
they are that should not even be a
question but the fact that it was a
question is really disturbing
labert continues to change the way
people view members of the lgbtq+
community and the transgender community
and her new documentary disclosure
disclosure examines the history of
transgender visibility from the earliest
days of cinema to current scripted
dramas and she hopes the film will
better represent trans people in media
this moment with the Supreme Court is a
beautiful thing but we know we've had
the Civil Rights Act see you know you
know for 56 years and that doesn't
necessarily mean that racism has
disappeared it doesn't mean that sexism
has disappeared that's these parts and
minds of people also must be changed and
that is what our media representations
the power to do I think that's what that
feels like disclosure have the
palliative premiering on June 19th
disclosure features interviews with
Laverne and many others as they share
their own experiences of seeing
themselves represented on screen we are
everywhere and you never know what those
positive images do for other people you
never know for the first time trans
people are taking center of their own
storytelling at this point where we're
talking really about unprecedented trans
visibility oh hey there if you want more
LGBTQ news and exclusive interviews
click Subscribe or watch these videos